for the family of uh capitol officer
um sicknick
who uh has died in the line of duty
our sympathies and our concerns go out
for to his family
and the people responsible should be
held accountable
and they will be but today
today i'm pleased to announce the latest
members of our
economic team with this with their
announcement
i'm proud to announce we have finished
naming our
cabinet saving the best for last year
24 outstanding women and men
who will get our country moving again
and
who are going to restore trust in our
government again and who all of whom are
ready
on day one to do their job
this is a cabinet that i promised you
and i fulfill that promise it looks like
america
it taps into the full range of talent we
have on our nation and we have immense
talent
it's a historic cabinet this will be the
first cabinet ever
that is evenly composed with as many
women as
men in the cabinet this will be the
first cabinet ever
with a majority of people of color
occupying
this cabinet and it has more than a
dozen history-making appointments
including
the first woman secretary of treasury
first african-american defense secretary
the first openly gay cabinet member and
the first native american cabinet
secretary
we're also on track we named a record 50
high level appointments that are subject
to president confirmation
more than any president ever elected has
done
we've done our job we've begun my my job
of naming these people is my expectation
and hope
that the senate will now move to confirm
these nominees
promptly and fairly this is especially
the case for the nominees of secretary
of state
defense treasury homeland security i
nominated them back in november
given what our country has been through
the last four years the last few days
given the threats and the risks in this
world they should be confirmed as close
to january 20th
as possible there should be no vacancies
at state defense and treasury and
homeland security
and we will remain in this dark winter
pandemic
and with the economic crisis that's
deepening and we have no time to lose
with regard to the entire team consider
the december jobs report released today
the anxiety and fear of the women and
men out there
reminds me of when president obama and i
were sworn in during the great recession
of 2009 the december jobs move this
december jobs report
shows millions of americans are still
hurting
through no fault of their own
we lost another 140 000 jobs
the first negative jobs report since the
height of the pandemic in the spring
more people more people have just lost a
job
while many have been out of work for a
long time
and the ongoing gap between black latino
and black and latino unemployment
remains much too large that gap
and in many ways the jobs report
is a pandemic report with the pandemic
raging people are losing work and losing
hope
the hospital industry restaurant bars
lost more than 270
excuse me 372 000 jobs
state and local governments are slashing
jobs 20
000 local educators lost their jobs just
last month
in the midst of this pandemic there are
millions of people out of work
unable to pay the rent or the mortgage
they're waiting in line for
hours and to get mon get food from a
food bank think of this the united
states of america
people are lined up for miles on their
automobiles
waiting to get a meal to put on the
table to feed their family
and they're left staring at the ceiling
so many unable to sleep
worried will they have their health
insurance wondering if they'll be okay
the bottom line is the job report shows
we need to provide more immediate relief
for working families and businesses now
now not just to help them get
on the other side of this painful crisis
but a larger purpose
to avoid a broader economic cost that
exists out there that will happen
due to long-term unemployment hunger
homelessness and business failings
but by acting the vast majority of
leading economists suggest
that that's what we need to do to revive
the economy
in fact economic research confirms that
with conditions like the crisis today
especially with such low interest rates
taking immediate action even with
deficit finances going to help the
economy
long term and short term reduce scarring
in the workforce
increase growth and reduce our national
debt
burden failure to act will have the
opposite effect
i've said before the bipartisan covert
relief package passed in december
was a very important step but just a
down payment
next week i'll be here with you all
laying out the groundwork
for the next coveted economic relief
package that meets the critical moment
of our economy and our country we face
at the moment
for example vaccines give us hope
but the rollout has been a travesty
this will be the greatest operational
challenge
the greatest operational challenge we
will ever face
as a nation we're going to need billions
of dollars
to get the vaccines from a vial into
someone's arm
the vaccination for millions of
americans
we're also going to need tens of
millions of dollars to help reopen our
schools and
open them safely state local
tribal communities need tens of billions
of dollars to keep educators
police officers firefighters and other
first responders
and public health workers on the job we
need
more direct relief flowing to families
small businesses including finishing the
job of getting people that two thousand
dollars in relief direct payment
600 is simply not enough when you have
to choose between paying rent
putting food on the table keeping the
lights on
i also hope the democratic control of
the house and senate will raise the odds
of prompt action on increasing the
minimum wage
i've long said that we need to reward
work not just wealth in this country
people in both parties now recognize
it's time to raise the minimum wage
so hard-working people earn at least 15
an hour minimum no one no one should
work as
millions are doing today 40 hours a week
at a job
and still live below the poverty line
they're entitled to at least the 15
minimum wage per hour folks
big focus will also be on small
businesses
and how to correct the current
administration's failures to get relief
to main street small businesses
that are most in need mom and pop stores
are the backbone of the economy and
they're also as you all know
they're the glue that holds communities
together
and holds them together but today
more than one in four small businesses
are not open
at least four hundred thousand are
closed for good
as a month goes by a third of
black-owned businesses
and more than a fifth of latino-owned
businesses and more than a quarter of
native american-owned businesses
have less than one month in reserves to
cover expenses
previous amounts of economic previous
rounds of economic relief
last year helped millions of small
businesses stay afloat
and keep employees in the payroll but
there were clear problems
black and brown-owned small businesses
had less access to that relief
mom and pop shops were often the last in
line
while big well-connected businesses
jumped in front of the line
and got more relief and got it faster
and at every turn
this administration the trump
administration
has undermined accountability for every
tax dollar spent
weakening oversight firing inspector
generals
so it's no surprise an independent
watchdog found that
tens of thousands of ineligible
companies
receive relief they should not have
including from fraud and abuse
siphoning off support for their very
small businesses that are the
are are that needed so badly
but the good news is that the relief
package passed last month
provides additional aid to small
business and workers but as i said from
the beginning
the need to make sure that relief and
future relief reaches everyone who needs
it
we need to do more these relief dollars
will start to flow quickly
potentially while the current
administration is still in office
and they may send out money that they
won't have any control over
but for what for what we have to control
need control over i want to be very
clear what my priorities are
for distributing this emergency age
swiftly and equitably
our focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
but are facing real economic hardships
through no fall of their own
our priority will be black latino asian
and native american-owned small
businesses women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
but we're going to make a concerted
effort to help small businesses in
low-income communities
in big cities small towns rural
communities
that have faced systemic barriers to
relief
think of the mom-and-pop owner with a
couple of employees
who can't pick up the phone and call the
banker who doesn't have a lawyer
an accountant to help them through this
complicated process
to know if they're even qualified or who
simply didn't know
where where this relief was available in
the first place
we went through this down when we were
trying to bring when we brought
detroit back off his knees as we saw in
this morning's job report
restaurants bars and hospitality
industry had been slammed
by this virus we're going to direct
relief to those businesses and others
that have been
so badly hit hit the hardest
we owe them that support to help them
get
through the other side of this crisis
and i promise you we will investigate
and prosecute
waste and fraud in these programs so the
money goes to the companies that deserve
it
and will use it to help their employees
and their communities
when the president when my president
president obama asked me to handle
implement the recovery act
along with don who helped me a great
deal we invested more than 800 billion
dollars in our economy to help recover
rebuild and less than two-thirds of one
percent waste fraud or abuse occurred
we know how to do this we know how
important
predictability and clarity are to small
businesses
from day one this administration
work to ensure that small businesses and
financial institutions
in every community understand the rules
for these programs
the resources available to them where
they can turn for technical assistance
if they need it
we will have navigators who help guide
them through each step of this process
until the money they need is in their
bank account
and to the lenders participating in
these programs you should move quickly
without delay
to begin extending relief but i
urge you not to to not disabuse
these funds not assuming
not not to disperse these funds in the
same
inequitable way you have in the past
here's my commitment
in return we'll make our our
expectations
of you crystal clear the banks so that
you can quickly and equitably deliver
relief
to the communities that you serve unlike
what's been happening in many places
the bottom line is we're in the midst of
the most economic
unequal economic and jobs crisis in
modern history
congress needs to act as quickly as
possible on all the issues
i just laid out that's how we can
contain the pandemic
build back better with an economy that
works for all americans
and this is a team that's going to help
get that done
for secretary of commerce i nominate
governor gina raimondo of rhode island
the daughter of a working class family
who knows us like when her parents
factory job was shipped overseas
she never took her parents sacrifices
for granted
she created an innovative loan program
that helped minority-owned and
women-owned businesses
access the capital they need but wasn't
always available
she's worked with employers to design
skill training programs
so the local workers would be equipped
to take the good paying jobs
in their own communities she's put rhode
island
on the path to achieving 100 renewable
energy
and should be a key player in helping
position the united states as a global
leader in the 21st century clean energy
economy
and she knows what her fellow governors
democrats and republicans alike
are dealing with on the front lines of
the pandemic and economic crisis they're
facing
and how we can all partner together as
one nation and contain
kova 19 to build back better i'm honored
governor you're willing to join the
administration
and uh really looking forward to working
with you
for secretary labor i nominated a good
friend
and a stand-up guy marty walsh of boston
son of irish immigrants from his only
downside he's not
they're not from mayo they're from
galway
from galway moved to boston
marty was born and raised in dorchester
i know him
tough as nails diagnosed with cancer at
age seven
beat it at age 11. joined the laborers
union
2223 at age 21
elected to the state legislature became
union president
and graduated from college at age 42.
he's now in his second term as the
successful mayor
of the iconic american city of boston
who always puts working people first
fighting for a fifteen dollar minimum
wage paid family leave
providing frontline workers with
emergency child care
and protective equipment they need marty
understands like i do that the middle
class built this country and unions
built the middle class he sees how union
workers have been holding this country
together during this crisis
healthcare workers keeping our hospitals
safe clean and effective
and efficient i might add public service
workers
fighting against budget shortfalls to
keep communities afloat
port workers car haulers warehouse
workers folks
keeping our air and rail systems running
they're literally what's keeping us
going and they deserve a secretary of
labor
who knows how to build their power as
workers
who knows that when i say our future
will be made in america
it will be a future built by american
workers
a future with historic investments in
infrastructure clean energy
manufacturing
and so much more that's going to create
millions of good
paying jobs marty knows worker power
means not just protecting the right to
unionize
but encouraging unionization collective
bargaining
a fair labor standards act way back
didn't say
didn't just say you can have unions and
said the government should encourage
the formation of unions
it also means protecting pensions
ensuring worker safety
increasing the minimum wage ensuring
workers are paid
for the overtime they've earned like we
fought for in the obama bide
administration but this administration
has weakened
making sure that we have a trade policy
where for every decision we make
unions are at the table focused on
winning good jobs for american workers
this is one of the most important
departments to me i
trust mayor walls and i'm honored
united states senate and a thai vote
bernie and i agreed and madraq bernie
said we can't put control of the senate
at risk
on the outcome of a special election
vermont
and he agreed we couldn't take that
chance
we also discussed how we'd work together
travel the country together helping
marty meeting with working
men and women who'll feel forgotten and
left behind in this economy
we agreed that we'll work closely on our
shared agenda of increasing worker power
and to protect the dignity of work for
all working people
i want to thank bernie for his continued
friendship and leadership
i look forward to us working together
along with marty
he thinks i made a good choice
for administrator of the small business
administration i nominate
isabelle guzman isabel grew up in
california working alongside her
dad in a small veterinary business that
he built
she devoted an early understanding and
developed an early understanding
of what small business means to their
employees
into the neighborhood they support and
to the families whose dreams they
represent
she dedicated her career to creating
jobs to supporting entrepreneurs
as a senior official on the obama biden
small business administration
as director of california's office a
small business
and a small business advocate she worked
tirelessly to ensure that everyone with
an entrepreneurial spark
had a fair and equal shot at getting off
the ground and succeeding
the biden harris administration will be
locked in on helping small businesses
recover rebuild and remain the engines
of our economic
strength and as head of the sba
isabel will be leading a critical
mission not only to rescue small
business crisis but to provide the
capital
to entrepreneurs across the country so
they can innovate
create jobs and help lead us into
recovery i'm grateful
that she accepted the call to serve in
washington
for deputy commerce secretary nominate
i have to admit to you good loyal and
great friend
don graves don is a long-time entrusted
advisor
he was there at the treasury department
during the depths of the great recession
helping small businesses weather the
storm and stay afloat
when president obama asked me to lead
the effort to get detroit out of
bankruptcy and off its back
and on his feet again he said i could
take anyone in an administration
on my team to do it full-time so i went
to the treasury department
i tasked don to come over and work for
me
and work on it full-time it was the best
decision i ever made
and that if i'm not sure how he thinks
about that but i think it was the best
decision i've ever made
and did a great job working with city
officials state officials
on its road to recovery and by the way
it's the little things
it's getting to know what's happening on
the ground
remember how we're through the issue
about the number of buses and lights
street lights and like it gets down to
the nitty-gritty
of what has to be done we found out that
droid had a lot of qualified people but
during the
great recession almost everyone who knew
how to program
anything left so when we finally got it
back on his feet again we found out
there wasn't anybody left to know how to
turn on the street lights
literally run the sewer department so
now we got an outfit to come in
and we said find us hide some high-tech
people they came back oh is it 53
55 people they all happen to be
women most were minority
none had more than a high school degree
and a quarter of them only had a ged
and i remember even our very liberal
friends we told them we're doing this
they said i'm not going to do this well
guess what
in a 14 week was a 14 week program
they were taught how to program they
were taught how to do it all they ended
up putting the city back on its feet
every one of them left after that time
because we went to the graduation
the lowest starting salary of my
recollection is correct was 49
000 the highest 104 000
point is give people a chance americans
can do anything
given a shot he also helped me lead our
national strategy to equip workers with
the skills they need
for good paying job in the 21st century
in health care
i.t clean energy advanced manufacturing
and so much more
he was there to help me launch the
national cancer moonshot
and marshall a full resource for the
federal government to help end cancer as
we know it
the cancer survivor himself diagnosed
and treated
while he was working on this for me
don knows about hope and he knows about
resilience
i'm grateful to him and his wonderful
family
for once again answering the call to
serve
i want to thank you all thank your
families
and i don't want to embarrass them but
there's one guy up in the gallery here
tommy who's my buddy who is the son of
the governor
thanks tommy for supporting mom doing
this and to
american people i know these times are
tough
but i want you to know that we're going
to get through this
help is on the way these people know
what they're about
they know what it's like may god bless
you all
and may god protect our troops now what
i'd like to do is
turn this over to the team starting with
our next secretary of labor marty walsh
and after all said and done what i'll do
is i'll come back and answer some
questions thank you
marty the platform's yours pal
oh
thank you good afternoon
good afternoon mr president-elect madam
vice president-elect
thank you for this chance to work for
the american people
i want to begin by thanking my amazing
family
my wonderful husband andy my daughter
cece
my son tommy who's here in the balcony
thank you for your endless love and
support
we'll do this as a family
the mission of the commerce department
is a very simple one
to help spur good paying jobs
to empower entrepreneurs to innovate and
grow
to come together with working families
and american businesses to create new
opportunities
for all of us it's a simple but
vital mission
it's the same mission that's driven my
own life
and the path of my family across
generations
my grandfather was 14 years old when he
came to this country
he got on a boat by himself at 14 years
old from italy
he came to america in search of new
possibilities
he taught himself english late at night
in the providence public library
the library was open late at night
he started a family and the first
chapter of our family's
new american story
my father was the son of another italian
immigrant
a butcher butcher who helped
found the meat cutters union in rhode
island
which is now the ufcw local in rhode
island
and after serving in the navy and going
to college on the gi bill
my father went to work in manufacturing
spending most of his career at the
bulova watch factory
in providence
now i was the youngest of three kids
and there were six of us including my
grandfather
all in a small house sharing one
bathroom
now we didn't have a lot but we had
everything that we needed
until one day my dad came home and he
said the factory was going to close
the jobs were going overseas
and so after 28 years of dedicated work
he was pushed unceremoniously
into early retirement in his mid 50s
i have to tell you it was a very
difficult time for my family
and like so many american families
across this country today
we had to cut back cut back to make it
through
but my mom my mom kept our family
together and we did get through
and i went on to college and i started
to chase my own
of starting a business and creating jobs
for hard-working people
because i knew exactly what those jobs
would mean
what those jobs would mean for families
who had fallen on hard times
for communities where the factory had
shut down
and for a state that needed a shot in
the arm to get back on its feet
when i announced my run for governor
rhode island was in the midst of an
eight-month
streak as the state
with the highest unemployment rate in
the nation
but over the last six years
we've worked hard we fought back and
we've grown
our way back achieving a record number
of jobs
and the lowest unemployment rate in over
30 years
now we did that by bringing together our
workers
and businesses working together
coming together in common cause
we invested in our people in their
skills
their opportunities and their dreams
we helped new businesses launch and we
sparked others to hire and grow
responsibly
that's the same vision the same
faith in american workers
in american entrepreneurs that i
see in the build back better agenda
it's a vision for an inclusive recovery
that lifts up those who've been left
behind
it's a vision for a national effort that
provides skills
training and wrap-around supports to get
americans back to work
it's a vision for rebuilding american
manufacturing and
bringing back jobs to america from
overseas
and that's why i am ready to get to work
i am excited to get to work on a
national scale to help realize the
vision
of the president-elect and vice
president-elect
to help more hard-working families in
every community
write the next chapter of their own
american stories
so thank you thank you for this
opportunity
to serve the american people
so
thank you governor romano i look forward
to working with you in my role as well
uh mr president-elect madam president
vice president-elect
i want to thank you for the opportunity
to serve the american people
the word labor means everything to me
as you mentioned earlier mr vice pres mr
president-elect
my mother and father came to this
country as immigrants
from galway which is in ireland but from
a part of galway called kanamara
they brought with them their willing
hands their honest hearts
and hopes for the american dream but all
they needed
because my father joined the labors
union in boston was that opportunity
and that's why my parents were able to
raise my brother john and myself
with dignity and security in a
multi-ethnic
multi-racial working-class neighborhood
of dorchester
in the city of boston i followed my
father into that union
i learned what it took to turn an honest
day's work into an honest day's pay
i saw what fighting for good jobs good
benefits a safe workplace
does for the lives of hard-working men
and women in their families
and i fought for working people every
single day of my life since then
today we're at a crossroads in america
it's a time of great hardship working
people
holding the country together right now
i've seen it up close
as mayor of the city that i love boston
healthcare workers
first responders grocery store workers
delivery drivers postal workers
sanitation workers custodians
coming through for us under impossible
conditions
but this is this isn't just because the
covid crisis or the economic crisis
that threatens their well-being working
people
have been struggling for a long time
under the erosion of their rights
in the deep inequalities of race gender
and class
for the last four years they've been
under assault attacks on their rights
their livelihoods and the unions that
built the middle class
we are facing hard times but nobody's
tougher
than the american worker and now
now we have the opportunity to put power
back in the hands of working people all
across this country
and that is a good thing for our economy
and for our country
we can defend workers rights we can
strengthen collector bargaining
we can grow union membership we can
create
millions of good-paying jobs with
investments in infrastructure
clean energy and in high-tech
manufacturing
along with the workforce training to
help get those people into those good
jobs
this team the biden harris team has the
plans to make this happen
mr president-elect we spent many
memorable days together in my hometown
at a rally to support grocery store
workers fighting for their rights
and my inauguration as mayor and on a
day that i will never forget
at the boston marathon memorial where
you lifted up
our whole city spirits so i know that
from dorchester to scranton wilmington
to west virginia and all across this
great nation
your home and your heart are with the
working people
i look forward to working with you to
deliver good jobs
with dignity security prosperity and
purpose
to all american families and i look
forward to working
with this entire administration shoulder
to shoulder
with american workers to build back our
country better
thank you once again for this incredible
honor may god bless the american worker
and may god bless the united states of
america
good afternoon mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect i am honored
and truly thankful for this opportunity
to serve america's small businesses
together with you
and the exceptional and diverse team
you're assembling
i am eager to build our economy back
better in every community
the small business experience is
personal to me
i grew up in an entrepreneurial family
my father started his first veterinary
hospital when i was one years old
and i recall early childhood memories of
tagging along with him
to the hospitals to check on the animals
under his care
as i grew older i worked alongside my
dad at the family business
and witnessed his dedication to his
clients his employees in the community
i saw him spending endless hours wearing
multiple hats
tirelessly working to learn more and
grow the business
those memories have defined my career
and really
inspired my work still today along my
own path i have partnered to start
businesses and i have helped
entrepreneurs launch
and grow their firms i have advised a
startup minority-owned bank
and i have co-founded a consulting firm
for small business contractors
at the u.s small business administration
i was honored to help make a difference
on a national scale
i formed a deep passion for the sba's
work providing loans
investments contracts and counseling
to help entrepreneurs start and grow and
spur job creation
today as california's small business
advocate
i support the small businesses and
innovative startups of this fifth
largest economy
in the world focusing on ensuring the
economy works for everyone
as that's how we thrive together now
i'm honored to return to the sba at a
crossroads moment for small businesses
the dreams they embody the people they
lift up
and the communities they serve so many
small businesses across the country have
been devastated by the
pandemic and economic crisis a
disproportionate impact has fallen
as it often does on our businesses owned
by people of color
small businesses have had to adapt
quickly to survive
and chase down relief while facing
closures
drops in revenues shrinking cash flow
and increasing debt i know you believe
wholeheartedly mr president-elect and
madam vice president-elect
that all of our small businesses are
critical to our collective success
as a nation their american dreams
fuel our economy bring new ideas to
transform our lives for the better
and enliven every main street in america
and now more than ever our small
businesses need us
i share your commitment to help
strengthen this many small business
owners
who have seen their dreams and their
livelihoods
impacted by covid19
and to create opportunities and instill
greater equity
in all of the new startups that will
lead us to recovery
i am excited to get to work with the
incredible
mission-driven civil servants at the sba
to help america's small business owners
build better futures for their families
and their communities and i am grateful
for this opportunity
to serve thank you so much
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm honored and humbled to be here today
i first want to thank my family for
giving me
permission to once again serve the
american public
i've spent my career in government the
private sector
and non-profits finding ways to ensure
that economic opportunity
is inclusive and broad-based and as it
is for
all of us in our own ways it's personal
i come from a long line of small
business owners including one who owned
and operated the only african-american
owned
hotel in the mid to late 1800s just four
short blocks
from where the commerce department sits
today
but for too many people in this country
the chance to start
and grow a business to take their idea
into market
and sell all over the world remains
elusive all these years later
but we also know that government its
resources and its experience and capable
civil servants can help level the
playing field and empower people
communities and our economy to reach
their full potential
mr president-elect i saw it firsthand
when you and president obama
prevented another great depression and
helped us recover
rebuild and put us on the way to
resurgence i saw it in detroit
where we were able to provide the
partnership to help residents
businesses and leaders get their city
back on the feet again
and as we traveled the country meeting
with local leaders
labor unions business leaders and
educators
i saw how you brought people together to
ensure american workers
were equipped and matched with the
skills for jobs in their own communities
that also strengthened the economic
competitiveness of our nation
above all you showed me how to do it the
right way
to understand that service isn't about
those who serve
but the people we serve to spend the
extra time to really understand what
they're going through
and to know they aren't looking for us
to solve everything but to understand
and help
make their lives better i felt that most
through the cancer
moonshot you launched deeply personal to
both our families
that gave the american people a renewed
sense of hope in what we can do
as a nation with governor raimondo
mayor walsh isabel and the entire
economic team
we will govern by that high standard
that you and the vice president-elect
continue to serve to show
to revive the economy through the
pandemic and build it back better
to advance racial equity equity across
the board and to meet the existential
threat
of climate change with american jobs and
ingenuity
with your leadership i know this
administration will provide the american
people the support
they need to thrive and the opportunity
to turn their hopes
into lives of dignity and the respect
they deserve
thank you again for the opportunity to
serve
one of the fundamental values that the
president-elect and i
share is a belief in the dignity
of work we both understand
that a job is so much more than just a
paycheck
it's about dignity and respect
joe learned that lesson from his father
and i learned it from my mother
my mother taught me in her words and in
her actions
that no matter how you earn a living
whether you're a caregiver or a truck
driver a grocery store clerk or a small
business owner
every job has inherent
value and worth and every
worker everywhere has a right
to earn a living wage work in
safe and healthy conditions and pursue
a better life for themselves and their
family
we also know that right now the dignity
of an
honest day's work and the financial
stability of a steady income
are out of reach for millions of
americans
the december jobs report makes that very
clear
food banks as the president-elect has
said are being strained
trying to feed people who've had to
worry for the first time in their lives
about where they can find their next
meal
essential workers like the nurses joe
and i called over the holidays
continue to risk their own health and
the health of their
families for all of us small business
owners
from restaurants to barber shops to dry
cleaners they're hurting
and let's be clear those who run
america's
small businesses they're not just
business leaders
they are civic leaders they are
community leaders
they're the ones who sponsor the little
league team
and scholarships for local kids and all
kinds of local causes and activities
they're the ones who are role models in
their communities
and we've got to do right by them so
first and foremost as the
president-elect has said
we will provide more immediate relief we
must for working families and businesses
now and even as we address our immediate
crises
even as we work to contain this pandemic
and open
our economy responsibly we must also do
what president-elect biden and i have
pledged to do
we must build our economy back better
so that lift up everyone no matter what
you do for a living
or where you live whether it's in a
small town a big city
or anywhere in between and that means
providing
access to capital for small business
owners the economic engines of our
neighborhoods
so that they can create the jobs that
are in our communities and help our
communities thrive
it means making sure we're equipping
workers with the skills they need
for the jobs of the future and making
sure our entrepreneurs and businesses
continue to out-innovate and out-compete
the rest of the world and it means
protecting and expanding workers rights
by fighting for a higher minimum wage
and paid leave
safe and healthy workplaces and stronger
unions from working with unions as san
francisco's district attorney to helping
author the domestic workers bill of
rights in the united states senate
i can tell you from personal experience
that whether
it's the apprenticeships of the building
trades or the caregiving skills of home
health care workers
this is some of the most important work
being done in our country
the president-elect and i know that and
so
does this team we are announcing today
these are leaders and i've worked with
many of them who together with the rest
of our economic team
will help create millions of good paying
union jobs
and build an economy that is stronger
and fairer
for working people they are seasoned
public servants with track records
of not only standing up for workers and
unions
but creating and spurring innovation and
creating
opportunities for small business owners
and like president-elect biden and i
they will fight
to honor the dignity of work
the president-elect and i share a vision
of america where opportunity is within
reach
for all the people where everyone
can see a better and a brighter future
for themselves
and for their children with the
leadership of these public servants
and our entire economic team we will get
to work
building that america less than two
weeks
from today thank you so very much mr
president-elect
thank you guys
well let folks take some of your
questions
we'll have chances again this week to do
it
but uh let me yield
and you tell me who we're talking
mr president-elect while we have
been here as you've been announcing your
economic team we've learned that house
democrats are currently planning
planning to introduce articles of
impeachment against president trump
as soon as monday at that point it'll be
just a little over a week
before the president leaves office do
you believe this is a good idea
look i uh i've thought for a long long
time
that president trump wasn't fit to hold
the job that's why iran
and my job now
in 12 days
god willing i'll be president united
states of america
and i'm focused on the urgency of
three immediate concerns one
a virus getting under control
getting the vaccine from a vial into
people's arms i think
the way it's being done now has been
been very very sad
number two we've had 4 000 deaths
4 000 deaths yesterday and things
continue to rise to escalate
that's my number one concern to get the
virus under control
we lost over 125 000 jobs
this last month and people are really
really really in desperate shape and so
i'm focused on the virus
the vaccine and economic growth
what the congress decides to do is uh
is for them to decide but i'm going to
have to and they're going to have to be
ready
to hit the ground running because when
kamal and i are sworn in we're going to
be introducing immediately
significant pieces of legislation to
deal with the virus
deal with the economy and and deal with
economic growth so i'm we're going to do
our job
and the congress can decide how to
proceed with theirs
but if the democratic member of congress
were to call and ask for your advice
about whether they should proceed with
this what would you tell them
i tell them that's a decision for the
congress to make i'm focused on my job
and did you speak with house speaker
nancy pelosi before
this decision was made or is that a
conversation that's still
going to happen i'll be speaking with
nancy uh
and the democratic leadership this
afternoon as a matter of fact
about my agenda as well as whatever they
want to talk to me about
thanks
thank you mr president-elect thank you
okay i want to ask you about your agenda
in light of the jobs report that came
out today
you're going to be laying out the
principles of your plan
do you think that the need for in the
coveted relief bill
is greater than you anticipated and what
is the price tag that you're looking at
i've been told it could be
in the two to three trillion dollar
range and then
as it relates to the direct cash
payments you've
talked about the need for two thousand
dollar checks do you want to see that
in a senate stand-alone bill
as a way to speed up the process or do
you think those
those direct cash payments should be
part of the package that you're going to
be proposing well we're going to be
proposing an entire package
and uh parts of that package are of
equal consequence to people
unemployment insurance being able to uh
continue with rent forbearance
uh the whole whole range of issues um
and uh so that's number one i we think
that they all have to be dealt with
the price tag will be high but as i said
made scant reference to in my opening
comments
the overwhelming um
consensus among the leading economists
left right and center
is that in order to keep the economy
from collapsing this year
and getting much much worse we should be
investing significant amounts of money
right now to grow the economy
and that's a pretty wide consensus and
as you know moody's had done an analysis
of what i originally had been talking
about
and said that it was necessary to keep
the economy from going down
it would rise we'd create 18.6 million
jobs
create two trillion dollars more in
economic growth than
the other administration would this
outgoing administration
so it is necessary to spend the money
now
the answer is yes it will be in the
trillions of dollars
the entire package but it will be you
i'll be here
next thursday laying out in detail how
that package is going to go but the
basic
story is simple that if we don't act now
things are going to get much worse
and harder to get out of the hole later
so we have to invest now
secondly we're going to have to meet the
emergency needs of the american people
i mean literally i know you know this
ken that people are having trouble
just putting food in the table just
having to stay keep the payment of their
car
even able to turn the lights on there's
a dire dire need to act now
purely out of what is a humanitarian
need here at home
and thirdly we're going to in the third
stage of this
the whole story is we're going to have
to invest as i suggested throughout the
campaign
in infrastructure in healthcare and a
whole range of things
that are going to generate good paying
jobs that will allow us to grow the
economy
so that's a long answer to a short
question which is that
the idea of with interest rates as low
as they are with the fed having had its
power
sort of taken away in terms of what they
could do to help this administration
like
last it's important across the board
every major economist thinks we should
be investing in deficit spending
in order to generate economic growth and
i wanted to ask you about what took
place at the capitol this week
you served in the senate for 36 years
and importantly you were there in 1983
when there was an explosion in a senate
corridor you were there in 1998 when
two capitol police officers were were
shot you were there during the anthrax
attacks in 2001
what kind of an investigation needs to
take place and what steps needed to take
place to
improve the security of the capitol and
then secondly
how do you think uh the people who are
involved
in in these uh in the storming of the
capitol
how should they be treated by your
justice department should they be
treated as domestic terrorists
yes they should be treated as they're a
bunch of thugs insurrectionist
white supremacist anti-semites 6n
is not enough i mean come on you know
these shirts they're wearing
these are a bunch of thugs thugs
and they're terrorists domestic
terrorists and that'll be a judgment for
the
the justice department to make as to
what the charges should be
but the fact is they should be
prosecuted they should be
prosecuted the difference here is this
had the active
encouragement of a city president of the
united states
and the way in which the breakdown in
security occurred needs to be thoroughly
investigated i'm not going to prejudge
what it was but the idea the idea
that these people were able to just
march up the stairs
march in and do it in the way with we
had
there's a great debate i don't know the
answer great debate now was
is the governor of maryland correct when
he said that i was ready to send in the
national guard i couldn't get
authorization
what happened it deserves a full-blown
investigation
people be held accountable and act steps
taken that
something like this could never happen
again and the difference this time is
everybody every nation has dealt every
democracy is dealt with
individual terrorist attacks by
groups that are in very targeted
the largest target was 911 and the
buildings
well right down to blowing up you know a
bomb going off in the capitol when i was
there
two policemen but the idea that
thousands of people
thousands of people could be marching
up the steps of the united states
capital breaking windows breaking doors
forcing their way in stepping aside and
the photographs of
well i don't know what the circumstance
of the photograph would look like
you had some of the capitol police
taking selfies with these people
that has to be thoroughly investigated
the authorities responsible have to be
held
accountable for the failures that
occurred and we have to make sure that
this could never
ever happen again the damage done to our
reputation
around the world by a president united
states
encouraging a mob a mob this reminded me
more of
city of states i've visited
in the over the hundred countries i've
gone to and third
tin horn dictatorships it just cannot be
sustained
has to be immediately immediately
investigated
in depth and people have to be held
accountable and lastly do you think you
need to change any of the planning
for your inauguration as a result of
this
totally different entity is in charge of
the inauguration that was in charge of
protecting the capital the secret
service
i have great confidence in the secret
service i have great confidence and
their ability
to make sure that the the inauguration
goes
off goes off safely and goes off uh
without a hitch so it's a different so i
have confidence in
what is going in in the planning that's
been underway before this
and continues with the secret services
lead agency
thank you thank you
president-elect biden vice
president-elect harris good to see you
both
i want to pick up on something that you
just said about president trump actively
encouraging the insurrection
at the capitol given that given the
perceived threat that he poses
my question to you is not so much about
the role that congress should play in
impeachment but rather
should president trump in your
estimation remain in office
i didn't think look i've been saying
for now well over a year he is not
fit to serve he is not fit to serve
he's one of the most incompetent
presidents in the history of the united
states of america
and so the idea that i think he
shouldn't be out of office yesterday
is not the issue the question is
what happens with 14 days left to go or
13 days left to go
and i think that what
81 million people stood up and said it's
time for him to go
and the united states senate voted
93-6 to confirm
that we should be sworn in we were
we were duly elected so i think it's
important we get on with the business
getting him out of office the quickest
way that that will happen
is us being sworn in on the 20th what
action happens before or after that
is a judgment for the congress to make
but that's what i am looking forward to
him leaving office i was told that
on the way up here way over here that he
indicated he wasn't going to show up at
the uh
at the inauguration one of the few
things he and i have ever agreed on
it's a good thing i'm not showing up
earlier you'd said that
if uh you'd hope that he would show up
only in the sense that it was valuable
to send a signal to the world about the
transfer of power
you've clearly changed your perspective
on that because he has
clearly demonstrated he's exceeded even
my worst notions about him
he's been an embarrassment to the
country embarrassed us around the world
not worthy not worthy to hold that
office
if we were six months out we should be
moving
everything to get him out of office and
teaching them again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took
to get him out of office but i am
focused now
on us taking control as president and
vice president
on the 20th and to get our agenda moving
as quickly as we can
thank you another question about holding
public officials uh to account and this
is about an issue that's no longer a
headline but is no less
significant and serious and it's about
the more than 600 children who were
orphaned under the trump administration
as a result of the family separation
policy along the border during the
campaign you said that practice
was criminal can you commit will you
commit to making sure that the trump
administration officials
responsible for that policy will be held
to account
i'll commit that our justice department
and our investigative
arms will make judgments about who
is responsible how they're responsible
and whether or not the conduct is
criminal
across the board but as i said yesterday
i am not going to tell the justice
department who they should prosecute and
who they should not
that's a judgment that will be made by
the attorney general of the united
states of america
not influenced by me but there will be
a thorough thorough investigation of
who's responsible
and whether or not the responsibility is
criminal
and if that is the concluded the
attorney general will make that judgment
i will not
intervene to tell him who he should or
shouldn't indict or if he should have
died
and lastly beyond the covet plan which
you've detailed what is your
what are your legislative priorities
you've talked about infrastructure
you've talked about introducing an
immigration bill
after january 20th you'll control
democrats rather will control the house
and the senate
what do you do first two different
three different issues there and that
same question one
the commitments i made that i what i
would introduce
not necessarily we would move to but
introduce in the united states congress
first i will do
i will introduce an immigration bill
immediately and have it sent to the
appropriate committees to begin movement
i will in fact countermand
executive orders that the president has
in fact initiated
that are contrary to what i think is
either his authority and or
even if it's authority contrary to the
interest united states on environmental
issues and a whole range of other things
and thirdly i will immediately move
though
to the most urgent need of asking the
congress
to give me the financial wherewithal to
deal with the virus
to deal with the virus to be able to
move
so that we have operation warp speed
really working warp speed got
the the the vaccine to places
that were delivered but did not get them
from those vials into people's arms
and so it is a gigantic logistical
concern of how we do that i'm committed
to get 100 million shots in people's
arms
in the first 100 days i'm committed to
insisting that on all federal
jurisdictions
any place i have control as president
everyone will be mandated to wear a mask
an internet
interstate transportation as well as
federal facilities
and thirdly i'm committed to moving as
rapidly as possible
to get the vaccine to teachers and the
material
to children that can provide for the
safe opening of our schools
at the end of that beginning at the end
of that 100 days
they are the most urgent things we have
to do now
now immediately upon getting officers
it's going to be multiple things as you
well know because you're
a seasoned veteran of how this policy
how we work
and that is that there will be other
committees will be holding hearings on a
whole range of issues from
my positions on infrastructure what we
should be doing to generate
uh green economy how
and so on but in terms of the immediate
need to get
done not just introduced but to get done
voted on and get the money and resources
do it
it turns out that the most urgent need
is dealing with
the virus number one and economic relief
to
americans who through no fault of their
own are really getting battered
thank you
thank you mr president-elect and madam
vice president-elect i want to follow up
with respect to
what you just said about the
inauguration and that it's
a good thing that uh the president is
not coming but what about
the vice president mike pence he's
welcome
i think it's important that um the as
much as we can stick to
what have been the historical precedence
of how
and the circumstance in which an
administration changes
should be maintained and so if
mike if the vice president is welcome to
come
he'd be honored to have him there and uh
and to move forward in the transition
have you spoken to him at all no i
haven't
and you have called for unity and
healing
in this country but after the events of
wednesday
does that make your job easier or harder
i think it makes my job easier quite
frankly i've had a number of my
republican colleagues
former colleagues i've used to serve in
the senate for a long time
call me they are many of them are as
outraged and disappointed and
embarrassed and mortified
by the president's conduct as i am and
democrats are
and i think it's i i have said from the
beginning and i have not changed my view
my overarching objective is to unify
this country we must unify the country
and i think that you've heard me say
this before and i apologize for
repeating myself
but understandably the questions are
repetitive and good i mean they're
i'm not being critical of the question
and that is that there's two ways people
are inspired
by inspirational leaders and by terrible
leaders
by terrible leaders what this president
has done is rip the band-aid all the way
off
to let the country know who he is and
what he's about
and how thoroughly unfit for office he
is
and you see already a number of
republicans
i was so proud i know we're on opposite
sides i'll get criticized from some of
the people in my party for saying this
but i've worked very hard with and
against
the former the president the former soon
to be former majority leader mitch
mcconnell
i thought what he said on the floor of
the united states senate
was in fact the right thing to do
he stood up he's ashamed
i spoke with the guy i have enormous
respect for
enormous respect for and i ran against
him
mitt romney i spoke to mitt this morning
again
this is a man of enormous integrity
enormous integrity who lives his faith
there are so many more but there's
others who should be ashamed of
themselves
but they make up a minority of the
republican party this isn't about
republican democrat anymore
this is about people who understand
what this country is about and the
things we have to agree on a move
together
on i i just think that
if you look at it speaking to some of my
republican colleagues and i've spoken to
a number of them over the last
last month since i've been since we've
been elected
through recently as the day in which
this god-awful debacle was taking place
up in the hill
and uh i think they understand
that they're going to have to we need a
republican party we need an opposition
that's principled and strong
i think you're going to see them going
through this idea of
what constitutes the republican party
and
they're here some of my colleagues
republican colleagues talk about
how shameful it is of the way ted cruz
and others are dealing with this
how they're responsible as well for what
happened do you think some of them
should resign
should senator cruz or senator holly
resign
i think they should be just flat beaten
the next time they run
i think the american public has a real
good clear look at who they are
they're part of the big lie the big lie
i was being reminded by
a friend of mine maybe you were with me
i can't recall when
we're told that you know gobbles in the
great lie you keep repeating the lie
repeating the lie
well there was a print that when dresden
was bombed
firebombed there were 250 people
that were killed it was a 2 500
people were killed and gobble said no 25
000 or 250 000 were killed
and our papers printed that our papers
printed
it's the big lie people will know it's
one thing for one man
one woman to repeat the lie over and
over and over again
by the way trump said that before he ran
if you say it enough i'm going to
convince you
i'll say it enough the press is bad the
press is bad the press is bad the press
is bad
if he's the only one saying that that's
one thing but the acolytes that follow
him
like crews and others they are as
responsible as he is
and so it's not about whether or not
they get impeached
it's about whether or not they help can
continue to hold power because
the disgust the american people have for
their actions
there are decent people out there who
actually believe these lies
because i've heard it again and again i
was with a friend of mine who's a
medical doctor
telling me that his neighbor said to him
he lives in another state
his neighbor is a good person said but
you know doc
this is true there's a lot of there's a
lot of a lot of
chicanery that went on in this election
so tell me what well i just know there
was they say it is
they say it is this is a human condition
you say it and say it and say it and say
it
the degree to which it becomes corrosive
is in direct proportion of the number of
people who say it
and so it's interesting to me and i was
pleased to hear some of the more
prominent republicans say to me
that ted cruz's of the world are as
responsible
in terms of people believing the lies
as not as responsible but similarly
responsible like trump
but they didn't say go to the capitol
i'll be with you
follow that's a different story thank
you
thank you thank you all very very much
appreciate it thank you
all the available doses can you
guarantee that everybody can get their
second
shot on
that on time on friday on thursday
you